[Music]
hey kids you want to go on an adventure
well you can't because we're still in
quarantine at least in my country I
don't know about yours
so yeah I'm still in quarantine bored
out of my mind so I thought why not make
a little video and what better topic to
cover than a trailer that's been out for
almost a full year already picked apart
and scrutinized on every conceivable
level by the entire Selda community and
by now most people are tired of seeing
sounds good to me
now I'm gonna give myself a little bit
of a break here this video will be a lot
less heavy on editing and animation
actually I lied here's some very heavy
editing and animation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now that we have that out of the way the
reason I'm making this video
specifically is because I feel like the
trailer has never been really properly
represented when it comes to its
chronology and in the last year or so
many new discoveries and amazing
theories have come to light I was
browsing around YouTube for a while and
I found plenty of videos titled
something along the line of breath
awhile - trailer in chronological order
however I have yet to find one that
seems to have all the pieces in the
right place granted most of those videos
are over a year old so the trailer was
still brand new at the time I've added a
timestamp in the description in case you
only want to see the finalized result
however I do advise you stick with me so
you can see how I got to these
conclusions when looking at the trailer
it's obvious that Nintendo purposely
scrambled the shots around to make the
story events even more convoluted on top
of that there's also significant events
missing in between shots making it even
harder to piece this thing together
but that won't stop me from trying
here's all 28 shots in order of
appearance as presented in a trailer a
shot obviously being a self-contained
continuous clip without any cuts to make
things a little bit less messy in terms
of visuals I either shortened or
stretched some of the clips out to make
them all play at equal length now I just
want to warn you up front that there are
significant parts of this puzzle that
will require speculation aka I will
sometimes base the placement of a
specific clip on the most logical
conclusion nobody except the zelda team
has the true answers first I want to
make a distinction between two different
types of footage perspective shots and
abstract shots perspective shots being
pieces of footage that either feature a
character or features events that are
clearly observable by the characters in
question and abstract shots being clips
that are detached on the characters and
are purely aimed at us the audience as
an example the scene where a volley
flies up and sees the calamity unfolding
in the distance that's a perspective
shot it doesn't necessarily have to be
POV the zelda franchise as a whole
doesn't use many POV shots in general it
seems are mostly shot from a
third-person perspective but we are
basically observing what Ravalli is
seeing from a distance now some of the
shots from this cutscene where the
towers are rising up are
tract shots with the exception of the
great plateau tower link would likely
not be able to witness some of these
events happening from where he's
standing these shots are only here to
give context to the player with that
said these four shots right here I would
categorize as abstract the two with the
green particles up close perhaps could
be observed but it's pretty clear to me
that this was shown in this manner to
create a mystery for the trailer itself
the shot with the castle rising up is
self-evident if we are to assume that
link and Zelda are still underground
when this starts happening which i think
is the most likely scenario then this is
only meant for the audience to see what
is happening with Hyrule Castle from
afar now this shot is a tricky one on
one hand it could actually be something
that link and Zelda are seeing but
alternatively it could also be a camera
zoom into the cave to see what's
happening inside do keep in mind that
the original shot is very fast whereas
mine is slowed down actually it's not
even slowed down it's just a zooming of
a steel frame with some smoke effects
added to it because the original was
impossible to slow down without a lot of
distortion and artifacting I had to make
a guess on this one so for now I'm
categorizing it as an abstract shot all
these shots will still be included in
the final result of course now let's
start actually puzzling this thing
together there are three important
elements which dictate the order of the
footage the environment Lincoln Zelda's
tracking animal and the torches as you
will come to see these aspects change
throughout the trailer and serves as a
guide as to how events play out over
time now this is what I believe to be
the very first shot the reasons being is
that Lincoln Zelda I still have the
animal with them and they are both
carrying a torch keep that in mind for
later now let's work our way forward
some of the videos I've seen seem to put
this shot next or even before it but
this doesn't make sense first of all
there's only one wall on the left of
Zelda and this wall is not consistent
with the one we see with the cave
drawings on it not only that but Zelda
is clearly not looking at the wall
instead I propose that this is the next
clip Link and Zelda are taking a break
and they still have the animal with them
however if we go back to the previous
clip real quick we can see that actually
there's three torches here two carried
by Lincoln Zelda and a third one mounted
on the front of the animal here there's
only two left
either they lost one or they decided to
extinguish it temporarily to save it for
later next we have the bridge scene and
this is where one of the first big
turning points take place if we zoom in
we can notice several details link and
Zelda are trying to get the animal to
cross this gap to no avail if we look
very closely we can see that there are
once again three torches lit one being
held by Zelda and the other two are on
the animal the reason I know who is who
is because the end of Zelda sleeves are
white whereas link has black sleeves so
link is the one pushing Zelda is pulling
next is this clip the animal is missing
probably still stuck at the bridge and
notice that we are now down to one torch
which leads me to believe that either
link lost his torch trying to jump
across the bridge or they might have
simply decided to leave the other
torches on the animal so they would have
an easy time finding it under return
journey you will also soon notice that
from this point on they will start
passing the torch between each other
many times I realized that there's a
significant amount of people that seem
to think that this is the exact moment
that Zelda sees Ganondorf for the first
time but not likely first of all the
lighting and environment doesn't match
up the room where Ganondorf resides in
is very greenly lit and a lot darker
second is Link's reaction if this was
indeed the moment they saw ganondorf's
corpse why then is link looking at Zelda
in such a questioning manner as if to
say what is it what do you see Zelda is
clearly looking at something that only
she has an interest in or understanding
of again she is the scholar here so link
would be oblivious in such a situation
the final nail in the coffin is that in
the shot where we actually see Link and
Zelda are staring at Ganondorf it's link
who's holding the torch not Zelda so
exactly what is it that Zelda sees that
ruffles her feathers why the cave
paintings of course even the angle
matches up the paintings seem to be
slightly above eye level so we can see
Zelda scanning up the wall discovering
the picture of Ganondorf and this is
what gets her attention as a matter of
fact you could even split this shot into
two pieces and then mix them together
which would look something like this
so far so good right well you will soon
see that it's gonna get a hell of a lot
more difficult and speculative from here
on out
for the next piece of the puzzle I chose
this shot right here now you could say
wait isn't this the entrance to the cave
isn't this supposed to be at the very
beginning I don't believe it is I'm
quite certain that this is the entrance
to the room where Ganondorf is sealed
not the entrance to the entire cave
system first of all aesthetically it
looks like this door is already on the
ground and the decorations on the
entrance itself seem to depict Ganon in
his pig form which indicates that this
is the chamber where he's being kept but
we need additional proof something to
link it to this specific room hmm ah Who
am I kidding you already know I thought
this through if we look at this clip
where the rat is being swallowed up by
malice we can see that unlike the rest
of the cave we've seen so far this wall
has a brick pattern as well as these
steps made from individual stone blocks
now let's zoom in on the entrance adjust
the brightness a little bit and yep it
definitely looks like the same type of
brick pattern the sides of the stairs
don't exactly match up with the ones we
see in the other shot but if we are to
assume that this hallway leads directly
into the room with Ganondorf then it's
possible that a similar stairs leading
down exists on the other side we can
actually see that when Link and Zelda
are looking at Ganondorf from a distance
they seem to be slightly elevated and
looking down also since the malleus
leaking away from Ganondorf seems to be
contained to this room alone and we
don't see it pop up anywhere else in the
cave system I think it's a safe bet that
this is indeed around the same area the
one thing we can't know is if during
this shot Lincoln Zelda are already
inside or if they're still on the
outside looking at the entrance if this
is before they enter this could actually
be a perspective shot not an abstract
one again the original shot is really
fast and not a slow zoom in like the one
you see here but this could just as well
have been sped up for the purpose of the
trailer next I decided to put in this
clip because from this shot Ganondorf is
seen from a lot further away than in
this over-the-shoulder view of Lincoln
Zeller gazing upon him after that I
added this top-down view this one was
very hard to give a definitive place we
have so many shots of Ganondorf with the
spiral and putting all of them
back-to-back seems like it would be too
repetitive after a couple of shots we
get the point so there has to be
something in between we can also see
that this is still before Lincoln Zelda
I get closer to Ganondorf as there's no
one standing on this platform neither do
we see link or Zelda walking into frame
one quick thing to note looking at it
from this angle it's obvious that this
platform only has one way in and out
this bridge right here is the one we
will see collapse later but I'm getting
ahead of myself
we then transition to the shot of Link
and Zelda looking at Ganondorf and next
we follow up with these four shots I do
believe that these shots are sequential
just like in the original trailer the
way they flow into each other just makes
sense
I then follow up with what was
originally the opening segment this one
again is very hard to play since it's a
very abstract shot but as an editor I
figured in the last shot we saw the hand
up low so next we can follow up with
some particles up close this shot
doesn't really change or impact the flow
of the trailer anyway it could take
place between any of the clips where we
see the green spiral so far I've been
able to order most clips with relative
certainty without inserting too many
what-ifs but from this point this is
going to change however and I'm forced
to choose a scenario that is the most
logical based on what we can derive from
the trailer I've talked to multiple
theorists about this and the most likely
scenario in my eyes is the following the
cave collapse we see happening later on
is the result of Ganondorf using what
little strength he can gather up to
cause a small earthquake while still
being trapped inside the seal and I
fully support this theory
we've seen Ganondorf do something very
similar before in ocarina of time where
despite lying unconscious on the floor
using the last of his strength to
collapse the entire castle in a
desperate attempt to crush Link and
Zelda beneath the rubble so this is
definitely something that is within his
power Ganondorf has been sealed here
deep underground for millennia all you
can do is wait until enough of his
malice leaks out and builds up to create
another calamity which takes
approximately 10,000 years since his
most recent calamity failed once again
it's unlikely Ganondorf is gonna want to
wait another 10,000 years for his next
attempt
having Lincoln Zelda the keys to his
defeat in the same
with him grants him a unique opportunity
to break free by causing a cave collapse
and severely endangering the lives of
Link and Zelda he is basically forcing
the green hand that hasn't pinned down
to make a choice appalled the CEO or
save the lives of Zelda and link
remember Zelda carries the bloodline of
the goddess hylia
if Zelda dies that's it no more
reincarnated goddess
so obviously the hand chooses to save
them and break the seal setting
Ganondorf free so with this scenario in
mind we can finally piece together the
remaining parts of the trailer link has
passed the torch back to Zelda who
curiously approaches ganondorf's corpse
to investigate after which we see
ganondorf's fingers starting to twitch
reacting to her presence a flash of
ganondorf's past possibly symbolizing
his anger and frustration manifests on
the wall behind him the hands still
gripping onto his chests
this is when the earthquake is set into
motion we then cut to the full body shot
of Ganondorf the earth is beginning to
tremble now the clip I'm showing you
here is obviously slowed down but in the
original we can see that the camera is
severely shaking Zelda turns around in
fear as to what is happening notice that
she's no longer holding the torch she
was carrying earlier there's clearly a
missing part here that happens
off-camera in between these two clips
and if we skip forward a little bit we
can see that link is now yet again the
one carrying it so after taking a closer
look at Ganondorf if she handed the
torch back to link and for some reason
has started to walk back across the
bridge and towards the entrance whether
this is because she saw or heard
something near the entrance or wanted to
go grab a piece of equipment is anyone's
guess we see the ground shaking beneath
Zelda's feet and the bridge collapses
now you might argue that these two clips
could be ordered the other way around
first the ground shaking beneath her
feet and then she turns around but if we
look closely at the ground we can see
that she's already facing the light
source which in all probability is the
torch that link is holding so she's
already facing in that direction yeah
I'm getting into OCD territory when it
comes to the details right now next we
have link grabbing hold of Zelda to
prevent her from falling into the depths
below however notice how link is nowhere
near grabbing range when the bridge
collapsed
there is again a missing part here
either the bridge didn't fully collapse
right away giving Zelda time to run
across in grabblings hand or Zelda made
a leap towards the ledge at which point
link manages to grab her however with
the ground still shaking and Linc having
no solid footing Linc keels over towards
the chasm and they are both about to go
over the edge at which point the hand
breaks the seal and grabs link to pull
them back to safety with the seal now
broken the green spirals energy
disintegrates and Ganondorf springs to
life having finally been freed from his
agonizing prison a wave of malice bursts
from his chest hitting the ceiling with
tremendous force and then we come to our
little rodent friend right here the
placing of this shot is given away by
the type of malice we observe throughout
the trailer we see two types of malice
the more calm dimly-lit and swirling
strands surrounding Ganondorf before he
wakes up and the more bright red
aggressive kind we see in the previous
shot assuming that this creature is
somewhere near the entrance it would
make sense that after the malice hits
the ceiling it branches out into the
rest of the chamber and maybe even out
through the entrance itself I actually
have a little theory or idea of my own
regarding this particular shot but I
will save it for the very end of the
video so we can keep moving so if you
want to hear my thoughts on it make sure
to stay until after the end screen next
we see links hand getting possessed by
the green energy I was initially
thinking of putting this shot after the
part where the hand grabs link but then
I realized two things one it wouldn't
make sense for this to happen right
after link gets grabbed since well with
Lincoln's held are still dangling over
the chasm and all it would make sense if
they first be brought to safety while
all this other crazy stuff is going on
and we indeed see that by the time links
hand gets afflicted he has regained his
footing second and I'm ashamed I have
never noticed this before but it's
actually his left hand that gets grabbed
in this shot yet it's his right hand
that absorbs the green energy so it only
makes sense that this happens a bit
later maybe even after Ganondorf has
already taken off which he probably will
as soon as possible
Ganondorf is in a weakened mummified
state having failed to kill Lincoln
Zelda I doubt he's gonna want to stick
around to get obliterated by links fully
powered master
sword so yeah the green hand transfers
whatever power is still left inside it
to link and we end with the shot of
Ganondorf taking off with hyrule castle
whoo that was a mouthful so now let's
take a look at the finished product one
thing to mention though is that since
the trailer is now all chopped up and
stretched out I won't be able to use the
original audio anymore since that would
sound horrible so I added some sound
effects of my own and replace the music
with something else so let's roll the
clip
alright alright I'm sorry I couldn't
resist let's try that again
[Music]
[Music]
and with that I will conclude this video
a video that I estimated was gonna be
about seven minutes tops
that obviously panned out differently
thanks a lot for watching and I will see
you in the next video this is dawn
signing off and have a good one okay so
hear me out
what if Ganondorf purposely targets this
rat corrupting it and turning it into
some kind of malice infested monstrosity
in order to keep Link and Zelda busy so
he can make his escape not only that but
this monster he just created will serve
us the first tutorial enemy for link to
test out his new green hand ability
ever since Nintendo black crisis his
video there's been a lot of talk about
this green hand that's keeping Ganondorf
sealed being able to extract malice in
which case link and zelda might have to
fight it to weaken at first and when
it's weak enough you can use the green
hand ability to extract the malice from
it turning this Rous back to normal
Yes No maybe okay bye